today we are going to be speaking to
bill share
certainly a familiar face on the show
although in a literal sense
the the the current hairstyle and beard
makes him look a little bit different
than normal
uh bill share is a contributor to the
washington monthly
political magazine and real clear
politics and also also hosts the history
podcast
when america worked uh bill always great
to have you on
do i still hold the record for most
david paquitur appearances or have i
lost that
i think so there was a period where
richard wolff surpassed you
but you've taken it back now i think
which is good which is good
um okay so we've got the 1-6 commission
moving forward but that's not
a biden proposal joe biden has talked
about
he has this tax reform plan he has a
jobs plan
he has an infrastructure plan there are
different ideas for how
different of elements would be paid for
and disagreements as to the size of
packages and all of these different
things
if you just look at the the rest of this
year do any of those things get done
which is the most likely which is the
likely to benefit
biden the most politically well i think
biden has made clear
inaction is not an option in terms of
infrastructure
okay i don't think he can go back to the
voters in 2022
and said sorry i got bupkus but i fought
really hard
he needs something uh and what's
interesting is
what's happening with the 1-6 commission
which seems very
uh bitter partisan fractious
yes you got 35 house republicans that
came over but
mccarthy was against that mcconnell came
out against it
it seems like it's same old same old
moving farther and farther apart uh
while that's happening biden continues
to
meet with republican leaders on
infrastructure right
and mitch mcconnell of all people
says uh i would i think we can do 600
800 billion dollars now no democrats
aren't necessarily
over the moon about that but it's hardly
the same
as i want to make joe buying a one-term
president i i'm not going to give him
anything for it for anything
there is some and i understand people
can be
mistrustful and cynical about
mcconnell's motives here i don't
i'm not arguing that mcconnell is a
saint
or doing something on the goodness of
his heart but clearly there is something
there
that he does not want to be seen
as obstructionist on infrastructure
there is a worry on the republicans part
uh and the question is can bayern
exploit that
to get a bill with 60 votes which he may
need to get
if he cannot get partisan
reconciliation bill on infrastructure
well now so i guess i'm
i'm i've been thinking about whether the
fear of appearing obstructionist
is is warranted because i mean just to
think a little bit about the 1.9
trillion
coveted stimulus under biden where
people got the 1400
um there were two discussions when that
was going on
one will the democrats suffer if they
pass this without republican support
i think the the answer is clearly uh no
people got their 1400 bucks and they're
pleased with that and some even believe
that republicans actually had a role to
play we just
looked at a bunch of polling many of the
people who got the 1400 bucks don't know
that they got it only because of
democrats
the other side of that was will
republicans suffer in any way
for having not participated at all in a
coveted stimulus bill that was quite
popular with the american people
it seems the answer there is also sort
of no at least as far as i can tell
right now
so what i'm kind of getting to is if
democrats just keep doing stuff on their
own when they can and
the things that require 60 votes
obviously though they can't do that
is there really going to be any
consequence for anybody for democrats
just doing stuff on their own
what what's an unknown here is inflation
uh we don't know what the economy is
going to look like
six months from now one month from now
one year from now
we have these we have an inflationary
spike
uh in the past month but which the biden
people
say is temporary the fed thinks it's
temporary the fed thinks it can manage
it it's not going to get all it's not
going to go off the rails
well remember i mean it wasn't from
march to april it was april 21 compared
to april 20 where there was a complete
demand collapse
everything was cheaper than ever i mean
i think it's quite possible
that it's it's an artifact really well
there is all i mean there's also a
month-to-month inflation increase too oh
that one i haven't seen
the bigger spike is year to year right
yeah okay okay but there is a march
taper
also i hadn't seen that uh yeah but it
could it could just
be the weirdness of coming out of a
pandemic that will correct
itself yep or not uh
so i think both parties are
kind of waiting and watching to see
who's gonna get the better of that
argument
down the road uh but having said that
you know you're not seeing republicans
say we should not have
any infrastructure bill because we're in
the midst of inflation
and that would just make things worse
yeah because that's a long-term bill
that's for eight to ten years it's not
about today
uh and there are republicans that still
want to bring home some bacon
to their own states and districts so
and and on top of that i think i think i
can't say for as a fact
i think mcconnell wants to be able to
say he did something
he would like to obstruct a lot of other
things but once we were able to say hey
look
i'm a reasonable guy i met them halfway
on physical traditional infrastructure
and that gives me the credibility to
block him on all these other things
uh so if so i
that they are talking what the two
parties are saying on infrastructure
have overlap there the red lines that
are being drawn do not negate the
possibility of a compromise
and again biden can't come up with
nothing no
joe manchin could say okay forget the
republicans they're not being reasonable
here
uh we tried you you gave your best shot
i'll go with you on reconciliation right
now
he is not there yet and we don't know if
he's ever going to get there so you may
be right in saying hey democrats
can do this politically without
repercussion
that's only true if 50 senate democrats
agree to do that yeah doesn't agree
or something doesn't agree or what have
you then you just can't do it
uh and i think as long as republicans
are putting
semi-reasonable proposals on the table i
don't think a joe manchin pulls the plug
on the process
and that might require you to do that
kind of deal
one of the changes in the republican
party certainly during the trump era but
in particular in the last four months is
that while
okay mitch mcconnell is going to
meetings and a few republicans are going
to meetings to talk about things
the republican party is not really a
party of policy at this point in time
some members of the house just straight
up say it i mean madison cawthorne's
office has said
we're not a part we're not running a
policy office we're running a
communications office and we're doing
tweets and we're doing
memes and we're doing you know talking
about guns on the house floor on his
wheelchair and all of this different
stuff
at some point will that implode or can
that be viable
when republican voters don't seem to
mind the idea
of just getting in the way of democrats
and not really doing anything
well this is what both the democratic
and republican negotiators have to
consider i mean there's i think
there you look at the majority
republican party look at polls look at
the house caucus
this is you'd say this is a party still
obsessed with trump cult of personality
yeah not interested
in real legislating or governing just
want to fight culture war battles and
exploit grievances and how can you work
with that
but here you got liz cheney making the
minority point within the republican
party
we have to get back to being a party of
substance and policy we can't sustain
as a cult of personality party i'm not
quoting a verbatim here but i think
that's the gist of what she's saying
well yeah but also i mean i have to say
she voted with trump like 93
of the time the policy she wants to get
back to i don't know it's like
i'm i'm not sure that she's really that
different well though
she liz cheney wants to get back to
hawkish foreign policy
yeah she wants the republican party to
be a neocon for a party again
yeah that's her okay uh now
do you have in the senate enough
republicans
who take a longer view say look
we can't survive as a cult of
personality party
that may be fine if you want to hold on
to 200 house seats
but if you actually want to be a
majority again if you look at the
presidency again you want to have a set
of functions again that we have the
upper hand with we have to look beyond
the immediate passions
of our base and we have to show that we
can we can do it
and survive doing it uh this is an
opportunity
for the romneys and the portmans and
the the capitols and perhaps the
mcconnells to say
we can still do this bring home stuff
for our states and our districts
and people respect this for it and if so
if that sentiment is there
can biden ken schumer ken manchin can
they draw that out
and come up i mean the bill that
presumably can get done
is 800 billion traditional
infrastructure
without raising taxes on corporations or
not a lot on corporations
some pills some bitter pills are
democrats to swallow
in that but still something that the
body could go back to the public and say
i did this tangible stuff that we did
delivered for you reward us in 2022 and
2024
for it there is a potential for common
ground there
if both parties see short-term slash
long-term incentive for their own
parties
there is um i believe no
chance that the capital gains rate gets
increased the way joe biden has signaled
he would want to do
i think it's just one of those things
that in the end isn't going to happen
it seems very exciting to a lot of
people i think there's a very
interesting
budget calculation in terms of what it
would do it would be significant
i see that as an example of something
that is just is
destined to die and it's not happening
am i being unrealistic in my analysis of
that piece
uh not necessarily and look let me try
to let me try to tie a few threads
together
yes so biden has
two big tax proposals connected to
the american jobs plan and the american
families plan right the american jobs
plan which is
mostly traditional infrastructure but
goods gets a little non-traditional
long-term care
school construction things that
republicans don't count as
traditional um that's tied to the
corporate tax increases
uh and uh yo joe manchin has said i
don't want to go as far as you do joe
biden i'll meet you halfway there
uh so we already have some indication
that bait doesn't have 50 democrats for
his proposal as is republicans say we
don't want to touch
the trump tax cut at all right we want
to
increase user fees uh maybe increase the
gas tax maybe
maybe create a new vehicle mileage tax
which would hit
electric cars and hybrid cars more we
don't want that
what's that i don't want that well you
know it's not
crazy i mean mean we have functioned on
a user-paced principle
for highways for over 50 years it's not
a new idea that republicans have the
only newness is extending it to hybrid
electric cars
right so again if you're joe biden and
getting a bill
is first and foremost and
you can't get 50 for your ideal tax plan
that makes the republican plan more
relevant in the discussion so
biden may say you know what i don't need
the corporate tax hike here
now so let me add one other element here
what's the other big thing that biden
really
needs he needs to extend that
child tax credit expansion right that
is a signature policy achievement the
monthly
checks are going to start coming in july
but they expire
after december if they run out you've
not only lost your signature policy
achievement people are going to be mad
hey you gave me these checks and now you
cut me off
uh and this might have to get decided
during an inflationary spike where
people might say hey bud you put too
much money in the system you're over
you're overheating the economy
the only way you can argue you're not
going to overheat is what they pay for
by not having any deficit spending but
having those checks be offset
with other tax revenue which some
democrats like angus king who's
independent but caucus with democrats
have already said
i want that paid for you're not
going to get 100 so child tax credit
expansion 100 billion dollars a year
the corporate tax hike plan of bidens is
166 billion a year
and the taxes in the american families
plan which are on wealthy individuals
that's another 100 billion dollars a
year
right there's only so many pots of money
here
so if you need a hundred billion dollars
a year
to cover the child tax credit expansion
to extend it beyond 2021
that's probably going to be a
reconciliation bill you'll probably not
get republicans to come along and help
save your partisan policy achievement
so save your partisan tax proposal
for that and work with republicans on
something that's not
as partisan for the infrastructure bill
i think that's where the stars are most
likely to align
the thing i really continue not to
understand about the corporate tax rate
discussion and maybe this is by design
and this is exactly the theater that
they want
um you know the corporate tax rate being
21
28 or 35 it has a far smaller impact
than a lot of people believe first of
all because it doesn't apply to sole
proprietorships
it doesn't apply to llcs it doesn't
apply to s corporations all of which are
taxed as pass-through entities at the
personal income tax rate so then you've
got just the bucket of c corporations
and a few other specific entities
that are subject to the corporate tax
rate but many of them are paying zero or
nine or eleven or seven percent anyway
because of the extensive deductions and
a lack of a corporate
alternative minimum tax so i feel like
it's a sort of
insane asylum discussion about mansion
thinks this
and it was 35 and 28 when it's not
really the way that you capture tax
revenue from c
corporations anyway unless you deal with
the other stuff are both sides just
agreeing to pretend that's not an issue
well that's why it's relatively easy for
bia to say okay joe manchin i'll come
down
to 28 to 25 on the over income tax rate
because the bigger issue are the
loopholes
right how do i make sure they can't
escape paying the rate
at all uh but that's gonna be a very
hard thing to negotiate i think you can
negotiate with joe manchin
by some some middle ground there with
the joe manchin may not be exactly what
buying has right now but you get
something from him
much much harder to get that with
republicans yeah so
why try uh why kill yourself to get 60
votes on the corporate tax reform which
would probably be very very difficult to
be very very watered down when you
need some big money for the child tax
credit expansion
uh so that's why i think i mean again i
can't promise this is what's gonna
happen
maybe they go full partisan across the
board maybe
maybe they shoot the moon completely
because republicans are too uh are
too obstructionist i mean i can't negate
that possibility but so long as
republicans are in the game
it's the laws matches keeping them in
the game i think you got to keep in mind
that
you got to have a pay for in your back
pocket by the end of the year
especially if inflation is spiking and
you got to show
that you're paying for your checks
a lot to look forward to i think is the
point and certainly
as we get into 2022 things that i mean
the child tax credit may play
significantly in the 2022 midterm so
these are not
merely academic discussions i think is
fair to say
uh we've been speaking with bill share
contributor to the washington monthly
politico magazine and real clear
politics and of course host of the
history podcast
when america worked bill always great
having you on
my pleasure talk to you soon